[Applause]
[Music]
Argentina has a new president the
libertarian Javier mle for the first
time we can find a clearly Libertarian
president a guy who even declares
himself An Enemy of the State and of
everything that has to do with
government intervention this has
provoked all kinds of reactions but
above all there have been two that have
stood out those who consider him a
disciple of Donald Trump and those who
consider him an extreme right-wing
politician we are talking about a guy
whose career has been meteoric from
being practically unknown to just a few
years later becoming the president and
not just any president but one who comes
to power with a totally groundbreaking
promise to completely change the entire
economic political and social system of
Argentina in other words mle arrives as
a kind of bulldozzer with a mission as
clear as it is ambitious to demolish
once and for all the fundamental basis
of peronism best of all mle was not only
an unknown but also achieved this feat
without belonging to any of Argentina's
historical political formations he did
it by setting up his own party Freedom
advances as you have seen there are many
media Outlets analysts and politicians
who accuse him of being part of the
extreme right but is it really possible
to say something like that is mle part
of the extreme right and that is not all
as we've already told you he is also
compared to BS
Victor Orban and Donald Trump himself
very clearly he is a mini Trump trump is
an icon of this new form of extreme
populism and mle wants to emulate him so
the question is to what extent does
Javier M resemble Donald Trump yeah
bolsero or even Victor Orban does the
Argentinian lion really have so much in
common with the former president of the
United States the former president of
Brazil and the prime minister of Hungary
of course based on messages like this
one it would appear he has a lot in
common Donald Trump is one of the few
who has understood the battle against
socialism thank you so much president
Trump your presidency was an example for
all of us who defend the ideas of
freedom and I hope to meet you soon have
no doubt that we are going to make
Argentina great again our geopolitical
alignment is the United States and
Israel that is our International policy
we are not going to align ourselves with
Communists Malay himself has often
expressed his sympathy for all these
political players and of course they
have not hidden theirs for the movement
led by Malay either take a look a very
special congratulations to Javier Malay
on a great race for president of
Argentina the whole world was watching
and I am very proud of you you will turn
your country around and truly make
Argentina great
again nevertheless visual politic
viewers let's not be in such a hurry
it is true that we can see a clear
coincidence In Style Both melee and
Trump bsen Aro and even Orban tend to
have a very harsh tone they are
aggressive and all of them position
themselves as an alternative to the
system in a way they share a certain
populist tinge all of them are
characterized by clearly choosing an
opponent an enemy highlighting some star
and almost miraculous measure that they
repeat ad nauseum and for confronting
the media from a political messaging
point of view Trump's immigrants are the
same as mle's classes but guess what
that's it for the similarities the truth
is that on the big issues in positioning
and political agenda melee is as similar
to Trump Orban and bolsero as an egg is
to a chestnut to a certain extent Trump
balsero and Orban do have many
similarities however Argentina's new
president let's just say he belongs to a
completely different Club wait a minute
you don't believe me do you think we're
exaggerating well if you think so let's
start by making a comparison between
Javier M and Donald Trump although in
most cases this same comparison could be
applied to other leaders we mentioned
pay close attention because these are
the seven major political differences
between these two leaders who at their
core could not be more different but
before do you know what a Dos attack is
it consists in sending a high volume of
data to an IP address to overload the
network which makes if you are attacked
your internet unstable a simple click on
an email link or an Instagram message
for example can make your IP exposed
once the attacker has it they can launch
a Dos attack and disrupt your service so
what could we do well be very careful
don't click on strange links and use
nordvpn's threat protection tool to be
safe with novpn you will surf safely
since your IP address will be hidden in
case of an attempted dos attack on the
VPN address the VPN servers will handle
the attack and you will have no
disruptions in addition using nordvpn
you will be able to browse Without
Borders unlocking a whole world of
content and it is compatible with all
types of devices and you can include up
to six on the same account so don't wait
any longer check out nordvpn and get
four months extra on a 2-year plan by
going to nordvpn.com
slvp and if you change your mind after
trying it out don't worry nordvpn has a
30-day money back guarantee and now
let's get back to the
video
the commercial
wall okay I think we all know that this
matter is along with immigration one of
the great Hallmarks of the 45th
president of the United States of
America and also the first major
difference we can find with mle Trump is
a DieHard protectionist and the same
could be said to a certain extent about
balsero and Auburn these three
politicians are constantly talking about
growing local industry buying locally
made products and the like in fact free
trade is one of the issues that first
attracted Trump to Politics as early as
the 1980s he was appearing on television
programs denouncing Japan for stealing
from the United States with its exports
that is why when he announced his
candidacy for the Republican primaries
in 2015 he put trade precisely at the
center of his campaign China is killing
us the money they took out of the United
States is the greatest theft in the
history of our country and when he came
to government well let's just say he
didn't exactly stand still Trump
launched a trade war against the
European union he pulled the United
States out of the TPP the largest Free
Trade Agreement in history he launched a
major trade war against China imposing
heaps of tariffs and he threatened left
and right with commercial retaliation in
the end the result of all these measures
was a failure the trade deficit
continued to grow and according to
several studies the trade War cost
American families tens of billions of
dollars and destroyed more than 200,000
jobs but that's another story story and
okay some of you may be thinking Josh he
did that because of this and that but
it's not really that he was against free
trade right well now Trump is running
again in the Republican primaries and
guess what one of his star measures is
well Trump promises massive new tariffs
if elected risking global economic War
okay I'm sure some of you are thinking
here we go the Press is manipulating his
words again well look at what he says
himself I think that when companies come
in and dump their products in the United
States they should automatically pay say
a 10% tax exactly we're talking about
Trump advocating a general Tariff of
around 10% on any product entering the
United States to give you an idea that
would more than triple the average
tariff which is currently below 3% so
the question is what does mle say on
this subject well basically the
opposite mle wants to open Argentina's
borders to international trade in fact
fact in his government program he has
committed to eliminate tariffs and any
other restriction to International Trade
including quotas permits and
authorizations he even said things like
this about
mercosur so you see first major
difference let's move
on
close the Central
[Music]
Bank visual politic Community if we said
earlier that protectionism was a
Hallmark of trumpism I think no one will
have the slightest doubt that the
elimination of the central bank so that
politicians cannot get their hands on it
is one of mle's great political traits
in fact the new Argentine president made
dollarization and the closing of the
Central Bank his Flagship policy it was
something he vly argued for check it out
[Music]
m blames the central bank for many of
the Great ills of the Argentine economy
starting with inflation well perhaps
it's fair to say he blames the ability
of politicians to meddle with the
central bank and use it to finance their
every whim and monetize public debt
according to Malay this has destroyed
the pzo and Argentina's finances well do
you know what Trump is basically
advocating the opposite yes yes you
heard me
[Music]
correctly one of Trump's great and
constant criticisms during his time in
the White House was precisely the
independence of the Federal Reserve
Trump constantly tried to pressure them
to print more money lower rates and even
monetize the federal debt the Federal
Reserve should get our interest rates
down to zero or less and we should then
start to refinance our debt we know I
did a lot of lobbying it was external
pressure because nobody knows if you can
really do that or not but I did it
because I thought their interest rates
were too high and they finally lowered
their interest rates and keep in mind
rates Peaks at 2.5% while the US economy
was growing at a good pace and yet Trump
was complaining and pressuring the FED
again and again do you now understand
how the inflation Crisis began to brew
the fact is that the former president
did it during his time in the White
House and is doing it again now as a
candidate in the Republican primaries
Trump bemon High interest rates and
indicates he may push fed to lower
Central Bank Independence ha print more
money that was one of Trump's big work
workhorses because he knew that in the
short term it would stimulate the
economy which would improve his
popularity level and remember it's not
just us saying it he said it himself
people can't buy homes they can't do
anything I mean they can't borrow money
once again I remind you that we are
talking about rates around 2% and
whether you think it is better or worse
mle's opinion on this is exactly the
opposite no printing more money no
artificially inflating the national
economy and no monetizing public debt
and no pretty significant difference
don't you think of course we are not
done in fact Trump's insistence that the
FED increased the money supply has a lot
to do with the following two points pay
[Music]
attention putting out the fire with
gasoline okay both Trump and Malay and
also bonero and Orban talk about
lowering taxes that in theory may be a
point in common nevertheless it rests on
one fundamental difference mle wants to
lber taxes offsetting falling government
revenues with spending cuts in Trump's
case that's not so Trump wanted the FED
to lower rates print more money and buy
more government debt precisely to
finance his growing deficit in fact the
annual deficit growth during his
leadership ranks as the largest increase
relative to the size of the economy of
any president in US history he is second
only to George Washington and Abraham
Lincoln with one difference Trump did
not have to face Wars within the country
let's just say that the former American
president made public spending grow year
after year while on top of that he
lowered taxes the budget Gap was
enormous to give you an idea when he
came to the White House the deficit was
2.5% and in 2019 the public deficit had
reached
4.6% despite the fact that the country
was growing and the pandemic had not yet
arrived this is another important
difference because for mle zero deficit
and reducing public spending is a
priority and then to top it all off the
pandemic
arrived the
mountain by Mountain we are not talking
rocks and snow or anything like that but
rather the huge mountain of debt that
Donald Trump continued to accumulate
during only four years of government the
public debt grew by almost $7.8 trillion
that's more than $20,000 per inhabitant
crazy not only that when the pandemic
hit Trump clearly showed how he
advocated dealing with the crisis by
spending tons and tons of public money
he even went so far as to send checks to
families to spend in fact the federal
government's response to the covid
crisis alone following Trump's plan
exceeded 8% of GDP as a comparison
between 1933 and 1939 federal spending
grew under Roosevelt's New Deal by about
5% of GDP and the response to the Great
Recession of 2008 equaled 3% the result
of Trump's plan skyrocketing public debt
or rather even more
skyrocketing let me say again regardless
of whether you like these measures or
not assessing them is not the point of
this video the point is that once again
it goes in the opposite direction to
what mle
advocates
what's more how Trump had to finance
that huge budget Gap then he pressured
the Federal Reserve to lower rates and
buy public debt in this respect Trump's
moves were more similar to Sergio Massa
than Javier mes so neither on Central
Banking nor on how to lower taxes nor on
the level of public spending nor on
public debt nor on International Trade
do mle and Trump have shared positions
rather as you can see they are at
opposite ends of the spectrum of course
it's not all about the
economy
[Music]
abortion Malay is very clear and does
not mince his words he says that
abortion is murder and is furiously
against it he has even promised a
referendum to reverse the legislation
that was approved in Argentina in 2020 I
am against abortion openly because it
goes against the right to life
Argentina's new president has gone so
far as to say that people who are in
favor of abortion are and I quote
brainwashed by a murderous policy so
what about Donald Trump well let's just
say he doesn't have such a clear
position nor does it seem to be
something that is a priority for him in
1999 for example he publicly defended
women's rights to decide I'm I'm very
Pro ches I hate the concept of abortion
I hate it I hate everything it stands
for I cringe when I listen to people
debating the subject but you still I
just believe in choice that is a
position very similar to the one held
for instance by Joe Biden it is true
that he then boasts that under his
administration conservative judges were
chosen for the Supreme Court and this
brought down the Benchmark roie Wade
ruling of 1973 which recognized a
woman's right to have an abortion and
that this issue has now been shifted to
State policy but he has done that
because he knows that he cannot afford
to lose the support of many conservative
sectors but that yes at the same time
Trump refuses to support a national
restriction and in fact now in his
campaign we can find messages like this
one Trump calls Dan santis abortion ban
a terrible mistake drawing a from some
key Republicans to which Dan santis did
not hesitate to respond I don't know how
you can even make the claim that you are
pro-life if you're criticizing States
for enacting protections for babies that
have heartbeats so you see it's another
matter where melee and Trump play in
different leagues but let's go
on
[Music]
don't let them
in okay if we were saying earlier that
protectionism was one of the Hallmarks
of trumpism I think we will all agree
that immigration is the other big
feature Trump does not want immigrants
of any kind he Advocates ending illegal
immigration but also restricting and
limiting legal immigration in fact the
way he speaks about people arriving from
abroad is not exactly very welcoming if
you take a close look at his 2024
candidacy it is about just that further
restricting both illegal and legal
immigration not surprisingly he talks
about deporting millions of people ja
M's position on the other hand once
again is very different he is
conceptually and ideologically in favor
of much more open immigration systems in
his opinion the only problem with
immigration is the cost to Social
Services there are documents that prove
that in those countries that are more
open there is more Innovation more
growth so immigration is a good thing
when our grandparents or our parents
came they came to earn their bread by
the sweat of their brow and there was no
welfare state the problem arises with
immigration when there is a welfare
state that is why he has said that if
there were for example a system of
generalized vouchers or a private system
then he would support an open
immigration regime practically again it
is a position that is at odds with Trump
but visual politic Community we still
have one last
point ukra and various
tyrants at times mle has said that he
supports Trump's foreign Vision even so
when we get into the details things
change quite a bit those of us who
unhesitatingly defend a model of open
and free Society must join forces in
favor of an effective strategy to
confront the enemies of Freedom who as
in the past are once again trying to
drag Humanity back to Dark Times of
chaos and misery this has melee
supporting Ukraine and and Israel while
Trump is betting on stopping Aid to Kei
congratulations to Javier M on his
convincing victory in Argentina's
presidential elections I appreciate his
clear stance and support of Ukraine I
look forward to working together to
strengthen our cooperation and restore
International order based on
international law and let's not forget
encounters like this one surely surely
you all remember it don't
you Trump says North Korea's Kim very
and what does melee say well basically
that he wants absolutely nothing to do
with authoritarianism or communism that
at the level of private Commerce it is
all very well but at the level of
government
zilar so there you have it these are
seven of the big differences between
Trump and mle and also between mle and
bolsero and Orban and as you can see we
are not exactly talking about small or
inconsequential matters but about
absolutely key issues fundamental
pillars when it comes to shaping the
type of State argued for by one or the
other okay it's true melee and Trump do
have some overlap on issues like climate
change gun control and government
regulations yet as you have seen they
Advocate completely different models of
society and then regardless of whether
you like this character and the policies
he stands for the argument that he is
part of the extreme right that is
reported by many journalists well well
what do you want me to say not by a long
shot mle has promised to cut public
spending open borders lower taxes and
close the Central Bank he defends and
promotes freedom and has no problem with
gender background or sexuality so really
what does he have that would categorize
him as extreme right whatever the case
we could say that he is ultra liberal
libertarian or Ultra capitalist but
let's be honest when we talk about
extreme right we think of something very
different be that as it may the question
is will he be able to do it leave us
your answers in the
[Music]
comments